ich habe so unfassbar viele kommentare
von euch bekommen von wegen hey luca du
musst auf jeden fall mal auf die hilf
mir folge meine mutter macht sich an
meinen freund run reagiert und daher
reagiere ich da heute drauf schon so ein
richtiger standard sie anfangen da
rafinha kommt nochmal einen nagellack
gucken mal schauen wie diese sarafina
aussieht
also sie ist halt so übels voller sie
und sie haben wir noch nicht von vorne
gesehen aber bisher sieht sie aus wie
ein normales mädchen egal
die folge wie geht ihr wieder richtig
gut ich glaube ich sage das gerade zum
ersten mal habe ich habe gerade so
richtig bock auf hilf mir zu reagieren
also wir schon mal gesagt dass er
nochmals hier mit meinen freunden
rumhängen zu müssen
a
der titel ist ja wie bereits gesagt
meine mutter macht sich an meinen freund
ran also anscheinend ist dieser rafina
hier das mädchen ihr freund ist der jan
und die mutter wir immer schon mit ihren
freunden abhängen schauen ob die namen
jetzt der safina ihren freund aus spannt
[Musik]
schreiben vom 16 erwartest du das
wirklich dass ich ihn noch alles ist
damit der name falsch
alles hinterher schleppen es geht es
kann nicht mal was geschleppt werden
außer abgelaufenen joghurt ohne flasche
ketchup arbeiten ich glaube die safina
geht jetzt tatsächlich direkt arbeiten
du willst was jetzt platzt mir aber
langsam der kragen safina
ich habe gedacht du bis hierhin gekommen
um die schulden zu bezahlen ich kriege
mit
ach du scheiße es geht nicht nur darum
dass ihr anscheinend der freund
ausgespannt wird sondern dass sie auch
finanzielle probleme hat sarafina da
bist dabei hilft mir genau richtig
mit dem zigaretten und den prosecco von
einer mutter nämlich
alter das wird ja immer schlimmer die
mutter kaufte sich auf ihren prosecco
und kippen
der absolute wahnsinn was er jetzt schon
meine lieblings folge unter die kommt
hier alle nase lang mit irgendeinem
jungen mit irgendeinem jungen lover
dicke die ist ja mal komplett am arsch
nichts im kühlschrank oder ernährt sich
von zigaretten prosecco und jungen jungs
jungen jungs hört sich ein bisschen
komisch und jetzt kommt der ihr wieder
heiß gerade diese sarafina tut mir echt
heftig leid ich meinen sie ist ein ganz
liebes mädchen lebt einfach nur zu hause
ist gerade 16 geworden und die mal so
übel sah sie und spann tierfreunde aus
und können sie ganz nach nur prosecco
und kippen aber ich will mal gespannt
was dieser typ wie jetzt zu sagen hat
die aufgelaufenen schulden beim kiosk
besitzer hatte natürlich die mutter von
safina
also das ist ja echt der absolute
wahnsinn
der ist hier der stefan bartels
finanzexperte aus hamburger ist er extra
nach berlin beziehungsweise köln wo
diese serie hilf mir gedreht wird
hingeflogen und hat er gesagt die
aufgelaufenen schulden beim kiosk
besitzer haften natürlich die motoren
stefan das hätten wir ja gar nicht
gedacht für die schulden eines
minderjährigen kindes kommen die eltern
auf also da platzt mir hier echt sie das
ganze genauso einer fresse über monate
geduldet was du hier immer an schreiben
lässt nur das ist ein chaos und keine
suppenküche wartungsmission wenn ich
nicht meine kohle krieg erzählt er
andere saiten auf damit dann ach du
scheiße der hat er überhaupt schon nahm
er rüdiger ihr der sie vielleicht andere
saiten auf meine damen und händler ist
hier nicht mehr mit sub controller
wartungsmission wenn ihr wollt dass ich
öfter auf dieses wundervolle meisterwerk
hilft mir von rtl reagiere damian
nächste woche direkt eine neue reaktion
sarafina ist verzweifelt sie braucht
etwas zu essen und geht dabei also das
ist echt hardcore um hier so spannung
darzustellen zeigen die sarafina eine
abwechselnde toblerone
und jetzt greift sie sich auch noch eine
toblerone und jetzt auch noch diebstahl
begehen hier der rafina ich glaube dass
er nicht im knast heute da rafina
erstmal der toblerone geschaut
ist das ist das ist dass ihr freund
jetzt also die beiden rennen gehen
ineinander
küssen
manchmal wenn ich irgendein reihen
laufen flüssig den direktor
ich habe hier noch ein ziel für stress
und meiner mutter krasser rückblick auch
toller blick hier von der mutter ach du
scheiße jetzt kommt die band das ist ja
komplett sie die spiele nazis in einer
asi serie schulden sich gegenseitig geld
klauen 150 euro wie morgan
das kann doch nicht die ganze zeit ernst
bleiben die sache vielleicht stören wenn
du morgen das geld nicht hast deine
haare ab schenk dir den abgelaufenen
joghurt 10 euro von mir was sollen wir
uns dafür kaufen ja weil sie die aber
besser als gar nichts
die riskante kommt morgen keine sorge
sich immer auf sie aufpassen
die denken auch echt die welt in dem
western film al salafi das motto ach du
scheiße keinen gedanken
die ist ja so am arsch es klingelt hier
finden ein lebensmittel auf den tisch
ich sag dir hallo ketchup und joghurt
wird ist mir eigentlich einpacken ich
meine findest du befindest du diese
älter aus als 39
ach du heilige mutter gott
wenn das meine mutter war
er wäre ich schon längst in timbuktu
nein also diese anmache von elfi hat
schon etwas über griffiges
rub oyten ina hullmann ist das da
und die sagt ein absolutes tabu also
wenn du das erkannt hast dann bin ich ab
sofort auch therapeut lohn ein das sind
geht man alles 24 wirklich nicht
ich kann mir so was nicht angucken erich
ich kotz da innerlich ach du kacke
mutter sowas marica das ist ja unfassbar
kommt euch die mal an
das für lippen sieht aus wie ein pferd
alter ich möchte das ja immer sagen
freunde das geht hier nicht gegen die
personen persönlich also wenn das hier
beispielsweise die tabelle ist isabel
bis ein ganz ganz netter mensch aber die
person die du in dieser folge des spiels
ist absolute vollkatastrophe ich kriege
noch geld von ihr
300 das für 300 euro 140 euro 160 euro
zinsen weil wir so lange warten mussten
machen demnächst auch jude du willst du
eis essen gehen für drei euro alles gut
4,3 euro community stunde später wieder
herr jugendschutz hunderttausend euro
drei euro vom eis und 997 euro zinsen
weil du so lange gebraucht hat
das ist mathematik also die safina muss
irgendwo geld finden in ec karte ja was
ist das wohl
steht ja nicht einfach drauf bin von der
ec-karte und ich meine wer kennt es
nicht also ich habe auch den pin form
einer ec-karte fed auf einem notizzettel
stehen ganz weit vorn von meiner
ec-karte lege ich direkt neben den
fernseher
ja wenn ich eine ec-karte suchen würde
würde ich auch als erste sind die
besteckschublade schauen also seraphina
hat jetzt das geld doch noch 200 euro
übrig warum denn einfach so über die
trachtenkapelle oder das nächste problem
zu finden ob mir deinen schönen haare
schön ist der sex wird uns machen
wie wäre es dann mit schnipp schnapp
haare
jetzt sagen die beiden voller sie jetzt
stellt ihr die haare wenn ich mit ihnen
feiern geht menschen ziemlich abstoßend
alles was ich hatte
700 euro dürfen ihre minderjährigen
kinder nicht aus der wohnung schmeißen
danke stadt fahren
scheiße gehandelte sitzen dürfen und
schon wieder einen anderen typen
lasst mich jetzt irgendwo verschwinden
gold ging
ich kann mir das nicht mehr anschauen
freunde das ist ja die komplette voller
sie nummer ich weiß nicht was großes
kannst du jetzt gleich weiter nein sowas
nicht
[Musik]